michael holt
atlas what's up my man pleasure to be
with you
thank you so much for coming on the
program my pleasure thank you for having
me
it's an honor my man here we are number
700 together
yeah that's a good number it's a
beautiful number it's perfect
to share it i love having you on for
this one
yeah i'm grateful to be here man glad
we're connected yes
and what an epic topic
for two men
that have been focusing so much of their
energy on
this process to unpack
i love it we're going to be talking
about all things masculinity
spirituality well-being
flourishing so pumped for this
michael's got savage and saint he's got
tribe men's community he's got
a lot to share with us so i'm pumped for
this to be number 700
and you can find the links in the bio
below as we discuss
to look through the topics that we're
talking about because there's a lot of
good content over there
let's start with the journey
yes who were you growing up
how did you end up figuring out that
this was
your path um
in a nutshell i just got really lucky
the luckiest man alive
um i like to say
i think most people who are called to a
deep path of meditation
typically get just enough pain to
catalyze the inquiry
and not enough to actually destroy them
but enough to
dig a little deeper into what this is
all about so i grew up in philly
um in the suburbs outside of the city
blue collar neighborhood
and um i had a good childhood
good family good friends the
the vibe is in on the east coast
generally
and especially where i'm from is pretty
rough around the edges
you know so if you were to tell me then
or like in my late teens or even when i
moved out to la
at the age 24 that i would be
making my way in the world doing what i
do now i would have said
what what how's that even possible
so
yeah i mean
i found meditation i have a teacher who
says
people who are called to the practice
tend to occupy two extremes of the
spectrum if you extrapolate all of the
population on a bell curve
most people are in the middle life isn't
so good life isn't so bad things are
what they are
okay things are okay and then at the
other end are people who are really
jacked up
internally they just can't get in the
game you know they're really suffering
and then at the other extreme are people
who are very successful
from the outside looking in but because
they've gotten everything that they
thought they wanted
they're left feeling empty because it
doesn't fill them up
so anyway i come from the other end of
things there was a time in my life where
i was really
down and out depression using alcohol
getting in fights getting in trouble and
i got to the point where
i was like man this what is going on
i can't seem to stop myself from doing
these things
you know and so i wanted to come into
right relationship with my mind and
meditation
seemed like in desperation
i turned toward the path and luckily i
found some really really good teachers
who gave me some really really good
tools and
modeled what's possible in this practice
and uh
yeah i just i really went for it
it's interesting how you started that
off with
the idea that
we like to analogize the human to the
tree
and that if the nutrients
are deprived of the roots of the tree
then it can't flower the fruits
and similarly with the human if there's
an excessive amount of traumatic
deprivation
of nutrients it also can't produce fruit
but if there's a little bit
of deprivation of some nutrients it can
kind of act like as an
anti-fragile nudge to like take the
stressor
and incorporate it into its growth and
be stronger for having
the experience yeah i dig that good
analogy and
you're spot on with that because we've
had
back when our studio was in san
francisco and downtown
we had on stevenson street
on our back alley we had a lot of
souls that had undergone the extremely
severe deprivation of nutrients
and there's it's really tough to bounce
back but
maybe people like us and there's many
others that come on the program that
basically have identified that
they've taken their traumas and they've
turned them into treasures
and so i really appreciate how you
brought that up first
and then it was interesting hearing i
want to unpack this a little bit more
with you
as much as you're willing to share when
you're growing up
and you're falling into some of the
the alcohol the depression the fights
what
was that about how did it happen
and also what was this
turning point when did meditation i know
you said that there was a
a low and it was finding that last ditch
what's the thing that'll get me out
and did that happen before la
yes it did yeah and actually if i really
look back in my life
even as a very young boy i can remember
like um
being out even in the backyard or in
nature and just sitting still
and just getting very very still yes to
the point where i
felt like if i get still enough no one
can see me
so there was i think there was always
this soul calling to contemplative
practice
but as i got older into adolescence i
kind of lost my way
and yeah my father was
is a good man i think his father was
very hard on him so he that's how he
learned so there was some hardness in
the home
and then i ran around with a pack of
guys who were just like me
who had their own pain that they weren't
willing to confront and we're all
pushing each other and to get into more
trouble
and that starts when we're 11 12 and
just kind of snowballs till we're
you know getting older now we're getting
in serious trouble and i got to the
point where
i've my operating system as a
rambunctious young man was like this is
my wild youth
and all this trouble that i'm getting in
will sort itself out one day you know
i'm supposed to do this now so i have
some crazy stories
when i'm older but then i got i i got
into some real trouble and it was like
man this
isn't just gonna go away you know you
gotta have a look at yourself
and you gotta figure out why you do
these things
you have to you have to learn to love
yourself because at that point in my
life i
i really didn't i didn't and i
also didn't know that that that was um
that learning to love yourself was
actually a real act a radical act of
courage
this is not something that we were
taught where i'm from
i love that i love that this is a
frequent
happening for the young
especially boys
is that
do it for the stories yeah do it for the
story
definitely live those years and we got
some good old stories man
i've forgotten some of them totally and
then when you go back
to the homies they're like you'll
remember when
yeah yeah oh they're real quick to check
me
exactly exactly and i'm still great
friends with all those guys that came up
with yes
which is a blessing yeah but we got in
we got ourselves into some trouble
and then this pivotal moment though is
that
it's a check because
i remember similarly for me it's like
18 years old freshman year college
slamming two
of the super senior
quintuple shots back one after the but
then going
face first into the door into the side
of the door
right yeah and then the next day it's
like
it's not that big of a deal right but
then what is the
you know that's like the feather as the
trigger right
wake up but then
what happens is a couple months later
it's like you know caribou
like 151 bacardi rum and you know mixed
with a lot of sugar
pineapple juice and stuff it's like slam
slam
slam slam slam slam slam blackout drunk
in the hospital blood alcohol content
.33 almost dead
catheter rescued thank goodness to
medicine system
that's a sledgehammer because it forces
what you described
as consciousness needing to investigate
its own nature
right at what point am i going to
take my mind body spirit complex
entity to the realization of i
am need to treat this like a divine
vehicle yeah
and home and that
i can take what i experienced
as the sledgehammer this awakening that
i went through and i can become wise and
i can help
other people heal
integrate and achieve
more transcendent noble aims than
short-term style
behaviors like so and
that's something that i don't know if
all boys
actually get nudged
into doing because it's usually what
sends
men onto more of a spiritual path
yeah well not all boys go to not all
boys or young men go to that extreme
that you describe
that that you've done and i've done i
think for
me i'm an intense individual and when i
uh do something i go all the way in and
there was time my life where i went all
the way into being a
derelict it's my nature
so i just have to choose my addictions
very
carefully and now i've become quite
addicted to
health and the cultivation of a clear
mind and an open heart and
developing as a martial artist and being
of service and those are all really good
things to be addicted to because they
make me feel really good
yeah that's a huge transition okay so
let's
let's see how how it happened
when you started to realize that
we need to undergo this process of
investigating
our health our wellness our mind
our attention
our own awareness i know you said that
there were the experiences when you were
younger when you were just sitting and
very still
and that those are very important but
then the transition from the
boy to the man right walk us through
that and then the move to l.a
take us through that yeah so um like i
said i had gotten into some trouble with
the law
and that was kind of a wake-up call for
me like man
you you have to make some real changes
and i'd already
kind of been fostering an interest in
spirituality i was raised irish catholic
and i went to catholic grade school in
catholic high school and by the age of
17 before i even got out of the high
school i was like this is
bogus this don't make any sense and the
people who are teaching me this don't
even know what they're talking about
and i threw the baby out with the
bathwater i started reading
dawkins and hitchens and michelle omfrey
and like
i became like a militant atheist like
hardcore
and um i i don't know i i ran that
through my nervous system for a while i
think it's what i had to do to really
get rid of all the
things i'd been taught about what god is
and what i am and
there's an old man in the sky that gets
bummed out if i masturbate and i'm 14
years old
come on i love the analogy because i
also use that
in high level perception in chapter
7 the sorting algorithm the draining the
bath dirty bath water but
keeping the baby which is super
important but you you and i both went
through that process we drained
all the dirty bath water but then you
have to get to go back and get them yeah
yeah me too so i started um
i read a deepak chopra book it was
called the book of secrets
and i'm not really a huge fan of his now
um but i'd never read a book like that
before
and then that took me to reading some
eckhart tolle and then i started
sitting in my room you know i would set
the timer for 10 minutes i didn't know
what i was doing
i had no idea no training no
i just tried to sit there and i don't
know am i meditating yeah this is
meditating okay
but then i got curious enough in the
practice where i wanted to seek out a
teacher
i explored my area
in my neighborhood at that time there's
not really any meditation teachers
around
i went into the city i found a place
called the shambhala center
and i was totally outside my comfort
zone when i walked in there i mean this
was like a
big step outside the box of
my life and my environment and my
surroundings
but the place just didn't vibe with me
it was i don't know what it was
i wanted to jump out of my skin the
whole time i was there
um shortly thereafter i moved to los
angeles because i could just feel and i
just had this intuitive call that
i got to get out of here because i got
to get
right and i don't know if i can do it
here i need a real reset
so i came out here and that was philly
still yeah yeah
so i was 24 years old me and my best
friend
got in his car and cruised out we had a
buddy who was already living here so we
all got a place together in santa monica
and i was just blown away
yeah wow wow california
man there's no snow here dude [ __ ] it's
just total culture shock in a great way
fell in love with it you know i was
working on the east coast for a couple
summers as a beach lifeguard and i just
fell in love with the beach and so yeah
i got a spot in santa monica just went
to the beach every day and just
connected to nature and the spirit
there it is by this time i had found a
reputable teacher here in los angeles
and uh
just started to sit with him and listen
to what the guy had to say
and he's he's a man his name is george
haas we talked about him before
you know the deeper i get in my practice
the more
accurate my barometer for [ __ ] gets
and i know when someone's walking the
walk and i know when someone's talking
to talk
but even then back then i knew george
was walking the walk
because he was speaking about things
from a place of direct experience
and there was nothing necessarily
spiritual about him he's just a
just a guy who's a deep meditation
practitioner with
a very gentle way of being
and i learned a lot from him and uh i
did my best to commit to a daily
practice and i would you know
get two weeks in a row and then fail and
then you know
that that's just what you got to do but
then i
i decided to go sit on a retreat you
know for three days that was the first
retreat i ever did
and it was again that was at that time
in my life this was like
i might have i lost my [ __ ] what am i
doing
i'm out in the desert with a bunch of
hippies this is what i'm saying
and nothing really profound happened on
the on the three-day retreat
you know like i like to say there was no
moment where the
the clouds opened and the sun came down
and all was illuminated namaste
no no it was just really three days of
wrestling with my mind
yes but training that attention to keep
an eye on your mind
exactly for three whole days with no
distraction no eye contact no talking no
nothing i never did anything like that
before that's it
when i came back there was more space
yes
there was more opportunity for peace yes
there was more responsiveness and less
reactiveness and only three days so i
started thinking okay there's something
to this stuff so
then i go sit for a week and then sit
for two weeks and then sit for four
weeks and
just the practice unfolds in ways you
never thought possible you just have to
do it
yeah you know you just have to do it and
lucky for you for me
life handed me the circumstances that
said hey
give this a shot you know just enough
pain
to try yeah so
lucky me
bless the moments
that come through where there's a
an intuitive guidance compass
direction movement with
homies over to california
for both of us and that
that also guidance
of being with the ocean
being with mother nature on the beach
like that
also the the
again breaking through some of the
stereotypical taboos
that culture sort of
indoctrinates
onto the social fabric which are things
like
why would you ever go and sit in
complete silence
yeah man why would you waste your time
when i started
like really making retreat practice a
part of my year
like go sit three or four retreats a
year
people would ask me like yo are you okay
okay what's going on with you man make
you crazy
yeah now here's the thing that i would
say okay so i sat
for a four week retreat that's the
longest one i did
and people were like yo here what's
going on
let's say you live 95 years okay if
you're lucky we get to be that old maybe
100.
yeah to take one month
and just be quiet knowing that that one
month could radically change the course
of the rest of your life
it does it seems insane not to do it
exactly it seems like four weeks ain't
even
close to long enough exactly you know
it's a
sport it's a muscle it's a instrument
it's a technique it's a practice in the
sense it's a habit
to read baseline to higher states of
consciousness awareness being existence
one when they do any activity
understands the 10 000 hours of mastery
and so they know that
i pick up the basketball shoot the
three-pointers it's going to take me
time to become better
i pick up the saxophone play a little
bit it's going to take me time to get
better
everything people know coding writing
even socializing honestly authentically
with people
takes time and practice to get good at
and one thing that
we must figure out how to make sexy
is for consciousness to be instead of
do to investigate its own
awareness in a way like you said
that where it's experiential and it's
embodied and
we become better at sensing where it's
it's not
like that coming from a guru and
that we can tell that that difference
and so there's this
i like to use compound interest
as a way of of understanding this
so we basically have
this is in high level perception chapter
2 seed theory
that same seed that we were talking
about is over there on the left
the seed of the tree just like the seed
of the human getting its basic
nutrient needs
and then that second portion on that
left side says compound zone
and so this is where
if you undergo the experiences that
we're talking about at younger
ages you get approximately 30
000 days to live if you're about 82
years old
in your total of your life a third of
those
you're gonna spend sleeping
so you get about a thousand
months total so to spend
a month whether it's four one week
periods or one four-month period
and you're going to revisit throughout
your life but what happens is this is
compound interest in the sense that
through the process of learning
how to focus one's attention on
something like respiration
which we take twenty thousand breaths
every single day
thank you to the photosynthesis from
phytoplankton
and trees the interdependence
of all life that
over time
become more and more aware of that
monkey mind
and we hone in our focus more and more
and refine it
more and more and then what happens is
like you described
in many of the great spiritual
traditions and teachers talk about it's
very perennial wisdom is the idea of the
pause
is created we basically become jedis we
become ninjas
it's so beautiful what what's possible
once we realize
that we become sovereign in the sense
that
none of this sort of stimulus that
occurs
creates an a reactionary
immediate triggered response anymore but
we become sovereign
we slow down we cognize analyze
peace respect happiness first
then we formulate what we believe
is something that can help ameliorate
the situation
maybe take ourselves out of the
situation
there's so many different strategies but
it requires that that pause that
training that happens and then what's
nuts is that it doesn't just
happen for yourself
you know sri aurobindo and the mother
mural fossa talk a lot about
you don't do yoga for yourself you do
yoga for yourself
and everybody else yeah yeah even
unconsciously you don't realize that
you're doing it for everybody because
now your family all of your loved ones
your friends
your co-workers the community at large
everyone's experiencing your butterfly
effect
of uh elevated state of being
and so that's the compound zone that's
the compound life effect
like you described taking it to do it
now
especially in modernity where it's the
hyper
24 7 cycle
distraction yeah to do it now and to be
able to gain the skills
to actualize your deeper transcendent
purposes and north stars
into the world in a more refined and
jedi-like
way is crucial yeah i agree i think it
is an act of service
initially you know it's done for you you
know
when i found the practice it was because
my mind was making my life
hard harder than it had to be and i
wanted to
stop prevent it from telling me to do
bad
ideas or telling me awful things about
myself
but meditation is an act of service
because you cultivate a vibe
this is what my teacher shinzen says all
the time it's uh
it's a vibe and you don't have to talk
you don't
the people will benefit from your
practice you don't have to say anything
to them just by the way you stand in
line at the grocery store
you know you can intentionally cultivate
pleasant states
and then share that with people you can
also unconsciously
cultivate afflictive states and then
share that with people
so imagine if everyone took
responsibility for this body mind and
what's happening inside of it moment by
moment
and endeavored to plant seeds of
compassion and loving kindness and joy
you know that's possible anyone can do
it
and the more who do it the better and
that's why
i feel really passionate in my work
about sharing the tools that i've been
given that have made my life
so much better so much more beautiful so
much more peaceful
it's helped me to find work that i am uh
fulfilled by
and uh i'm just
i'm passionate about what i do and i'm
happy to share
what i've learned with the people who
are curious and
reach out to me
okay so we have
the beginnings of george haas
right george haas we have the
beginnings of sitting for longer periods
of time shattering through the taboos
uncovering the tools yourself that
transform you
and other people around you and your and
it's
it's becoming so salient in your life
that
savage and saint becomes born through
that
process okay take us along the birth of
that so i was i basically was living two
lives
uh in some sense at that point i was
working in the gyms as a fitness trainer
and uh i was like digging into the
meathead culture of just crushing it you
know
savage get it and i was also training
martial art
um i i was training muay thai kickboxing
penchaksyla filipino martial arts qigong
and tai chi
and self-defense and i'm also
sitting in circle with deep meditators
yogis and going on retreat
and so in this half of my life i feel
some you know people are very light
very fluid very kind maybe
almost to a detriment sometimes yes yes
and then on the other side is like this
hyper macho expression of masculinity
and
heart sparring and fighting you know
i've competed in the ring
and it's like okay these these need to
be brought together
yeah these need to be brought together
um
because i s i'd seen this modeled by a
few men who who i'd uh
who crossed my path that they were
absolute badasses like uh one guy can
remember
a client of mine back in the day he was
a competitive jiu jitsu fighter and i
was
training him in the gym this dude was a
savage
like he'll break your arms choke you out
there's nothing you can do to stop him
you know but he was the sweetest dude
the kindest gentlest dude
and i'm like wow i've never seen that
model before in my life i didn't know
that was possible
so i'm like you don't have to pick one
you can do both
and you should do both yeah you know we
talked a little bit about playing at the
extremes
and then you can play all the notes in
between so you're agile in your
expression
you know you can meet the demands of the
moment
you can do what needs to be done
whatever it is
and there's been times in my life where
the moment legitimately called for
some expression of savagery maybe not
violence but at least
the shoulders back show my teeth
you're not going to hurt this person
while i'm around and that was for the
greater good
and of course there's moments that life
is going to hand you where
love kindness compassion is called for
i mean often always really yeah
but i just love the idea of training to
do both
and so that was kind of the birth of the
savage insane philosophy and at a very
black and white level it's yeah
meditation is saint martial artist
savage
but the deeper i dig on the path and by
the way this is nothing new
you know this is nothing new i've just
put my own words on it
but it's like okay what if your
motivation in martial art
is to be uh
a man of strength and integrity that can
protect people from harm that's pretty
saintly what if your motivation
in meditation is to literally annihilate
the illusion of
of self to have the direct experience of
unity
to die before you die that's pretty
[ __ ] savage if you ask me
so one is within the other and they're
always dancing together
so it's fits the eye in the fishes
yeah it's the anion symbol that's why it
says nothing new it is
symbol i just stole it and i made it my
own thing your new brand yeah of course
yeah
it's beautiful the two poles and
synthesizing them i love it
yeah it's beautiful
you know what i just thought just came
to me today i saw this doberman i love
dobermans
and this doberman was so friendly and
sweet and i stopped and played with it
but i also knew this thing could rip my
face off but that just made me
just drew me even closer to it so it's
like
hold that vibration of being dangerous
but being
in complete control of yourself and
being totally committed
to keeping the peace that's what i feel
called to
practice and share
yeah another really interesting
yin yang style of this
is
the self-realization self-actualization
so there's the
you there's the self-realization of the
unity consciousness the god
consciousness the
the symphony and there's the
self-actualization of the unique artist
playing a instrument or a melody
in that symphony sure of achieving a
unique north star
gift to contribute to the world
and
all of the states in between and
attempting to
rise both of them up simultaneously
right it's a very savage and saint
it's very yin and yang and and
it's very the ascent and descent happen
at the same time
and so we very frequently
end up rising to
to big highs and then we end up
sinking to new lows and then those new
lows bring us
to new highs and so the these ascent and
descent happen
at the same time and so there's a
there's also a big synthesis with
isaac newton's laws of motion where you
have like in physics
the third law of motion for reaction
there's an equal and opposite reaction
and so you start beginning to see
patterns of well are there ways that
physicalism
actually synthesizes with consciousness
and spirituality
and then you really also get deeper into
the whole savage and saint thing as well
savage is very deeply physical yes
and saint is very deeply spiritual yes
and so this is perfect it's a great
brand
and it looks perfect i don't like to
think of it as a brand it's a living
philosophy this is my
is what um it's what i'm living living
philosophy yeah
and yeah to your point you know i was on
the beach today training
by myself and just in the flow shadow
boxing i had my kali sticks just moving
but it becomes very meditative like it's
i'm not the one doing it i'm watching it
happen
so that practice is a meditation in
itself it's i'm not sitting still you
don't have to sit still to meditate
yep you just have to pay attention and
you can pay attention whatever you're
doing
you know you reminded me of something
when you made this distinction between
self-realization and self-actualization
i was on a retreat once years ago and at
the end of the retreat the retreat
manager came
and uh spoke to the group and was giving
us instructions about how to pack up and
when to leave and stuff and she said
leave the
please leave your room cleaner than you
found it and i just thought about that
and it's like that's the path of
meditation is twofold
self-actualization and self-realization
the self-actualization is cleaning the
room
it's waking up into your life in this
moment and realizing how can i make this
body mind better what is my what was my
purpose what is my reason for being what
would fulfill me
that's cleaning the room up but then the
wisdom path is
leaving the room you know stepping
outside the
self-experience or at least tasting the
impermanence of the self-experience and
realizing that you are bigger than what
you thought you were
yes the heart path
and the wisdom path savage and the same
self-realization self-actualization
we have to do both yeah yes
at the poles at the extremes
is the self-realizing that
stays and dissolves in the mountaintop
and on the pull of
self actualizing is the
100 hour a week 52 week
a year grind one hour of sleep at night
working harder than smarter
type mentality towards even a goal
that's about
money and materialism and not about
ethics and bringing something of moral
virtue value into the world
we bring what we learn
in the self-realization
embodied anchored in our soul into
modernity into the social fabric
that's the gift the butterfly effect and
within that process the
self-actualization naturally turns to be
something that is more ethical more
moral more virtuous more
driven by bringing an augmentation to
the social fabric a unique
entrepreneurial idea or project that
solves a sustainable development goal
that does something along
those lines
and so
i like seeing it
as those two poles and also there's the
dirty bath water
in the two poles and there's the baby
and to synthesize them
into one yeah right right yeah one of
the things we talked about previously
i think the dirty bathwater on the
savage side is discipline
remember we talked about this shift from
discipline to harmony
this is something that i've been just it
has become more and more fascinating to
me in my own life and in
the work that i offer with the people
who who i work with
i just want to say jocko willing because
someone that comes to mind on the whole
sure discipline yeah yeah i would say
he's a little more balanced someone who
comes to mind for me
and this was someone brought this up on
a tribe call recently it was david
goggins
i'm not sure if you're familiar with
that yeah he has the 40 percent rule
which is super interesting right yeah he
pushed and
pushes him 100 miles of running
territory type thing
god bless him he's inspired a lot of
people
it's not for me to judge but discipline
can go too far
to the point where it becomes rigid and
you're
you're dragging yourself kicking and
screaming into things that you don't
actually want to do
but you're misguided in the fact that
this is somehow a good thing
but discipline must be cultivated first
before you can shift to harmony you
can't take someone who has
who has no you know direction or
they're they're too easy on themselves
and say oh yeah i'm just it's hard
well harmony wants me to eat this pint
of ice cream yeah no the discipline
must come first and it must become
pretty rigid
but then it must be given permission to
flower into harmony and that's when the
thing that's best for you and the thing
you want to do
are the best thing and i'm tasting
fleeting moments of harmony in my life
i'm not there yet
but i'm working toward it now here's the
bridge
embodiment and self-love when you live
inside your body
which sounds simple but it's
we we spend most of our attentional
resources from the neck up
we're very disconnected from our bodies
when you live inside your body
you feel your breath you feel your food
you know you feel the movement you can
feel in real time how certain things
affect the way you feel so you're more
apt and more likely to choose the things
that are best for you because you really
live here
i mean you really live here and then the
other one is self-love
and that's a skill that takes practice
depending on your conditioning
but it can be practiced and it maybe
feels forced at first but
it can become quite authentic if you
just stay in the practice and really you
know
repeat it and believe it and then you
start to treat yourself the way you
treat someone you love that's harmony
that's coming into harmony with yourself
so that's that's the bridge that's the
bridge and
in my view i would say sometimes i'll
see a man who's out of balance and
savagery
which means he's too disciplined and
part of he's abandoning a real part of
himself that he needs to confront
and feel that's likely emotional
but that's the warrior's work that's not
soft that's not hippy dippy
that's the warrior's work you have to
you have especially as men we have to
sit
and be present to how we f what we're
feeling
because if you don't those things that
you're feeling that you're not aware of
puppet your behavior and you find
yourself in some pretty shitty
situations and i'd live that
life i've done that and a lot of guys do
the vulnerability of strength the
radical turning toward
is the warrior's work you know yeah you
can run 100 miles you can
get into the ring you know you can train
hard whatever
try to sit still for three days yeah or
30 minutes yeah you know or 10 minutes
yeah yeah it's
is savage it is it is
those examples of the polls were really
interesting that we've been we've been
doing that right
this conversation over and over again
right
and showing the synthesis in between and
the
that is so beautiful and crucial because
you're right the discipline is such a
critical
aspect to it and then the harmony is as
well
and so is self-love embodiment
do you bringing up the precise
words and feelings the ground
into anchor sure so look at the other
end of the
of the uh continuum saintliness what
would out of balance and saintliness
look like oh yeah maybe this misguided
view that you should never
speak up for yourself or ruffle anyone's
feathers
or say what's true sacrifice your own
truth
you know like being nice rather than
being kind i think being kind is a good
thing to
strive for and sometimes being kind
requires having a difficult conversation
being nice is like always being polite
and never speaking up for yourself
or maybe this misguided view that a
man's inborn
quite natural sense of aggression is to
be castrated
and is just bad so
we have to find the balance between the
two and live in the middle
yeah this is buddha's big revelation
2 500 years ago that middle path that
middle way
yeah it works for all of the different
poles that we're talking about it's
perfect
really uh one of the interesting things
about it
is that for me
it's helped to
on that middle to
ebb a little bit more on
the side of
doing
in the sense of i see
a macro level picture of eight billion
people
on the planet and
you know four billion of them connected
in the interweb
space i see the
macro level movement of goods
across the planet ninety percent of all
world trade happening over
by sea over barges through barges
i'm watching indigenous wisdoms
become more and more
dug up and brought into modernity to
deal with the ethical and moral and
spiritual dilemmas
that are occurring in the
de-sacralization
of life as people feel like
cogs in an economic machine
and one of the big realizations for me
is as i'm undergoing this process of
anchoring these
elevated states of being dare i say
christ consciousness buddha
consciousness loud so confucius level
consciousness
in body in body butterfly affecting
in modernity those types of states of
being as much as i can
that my simultaneous recognition that
i have this deep passion to become more
and more familiar with
the decentralization technologies with
tokenomics
with quote light architecting
and so my sort of essence
being slightly more geared toward
loving doing loving doing
that wu way style effortless action
towards light architecting
but helping nudge people towards light
architecting
because we know we need the sustainable
development goal solved
we know that there's still almost a
billion people that don't have access to
that clean running water like
so many of us do we know that those
basic
nutrient needs for the seeds can be
met so that the beautiful fruits can
flower
of the unique individual's contributory
gifts
so it's almost
we have such a
uh immediate everything so
fast and so immediate around us and
sometimes it's hard to
hone in and focus and you're right that
we need to take the time to have that
compound interest
of investigating our own awareness our
body
to the extent at which we can become
a better
perfection
but i definitely do have more on the
on the doing because
i just know that there's a lot to do
to make the abundant future that our
hearts know is possible
that's something that has resonated with
me how does that
resonate with you yeah um
there is work to be done and i
appreciate your grand vision
you have a you you see a big landscape
and you have big goals and may they come
true i tend to add more on the being
side
yeah it's super interesting um i
i have one heart
mind and body that is within my capacity
to steward
and so that's primarily where i focus
and it ripples out yeah the work ripples
out
totally true yeah but that's my primary
area of focus that's not
i would like to think uh self-centered
or egocentric
because if everyone took that view
the world would transform itself but we
need doers and we need
we need beers we need big picture and we
need small picture yeah
so you and i tend to gravitate toward
opposite ends in that way but
c'est la vie yeah and
again sure been known the mother mural
fossa are so strong with this they talk
about simultaneity being key and to
basically never
separate into two and so even the idea
of splitting
the being and doing into two separate
things exactly yeah yeah
and so opposite sides of the same coin
we're doing the same work
yeah yeah yeah i know and this is then
then we can get in
we'll get into some metaphysics around
this type of stuff
also you know in a bit i want to mention
savage and saint has mostly been
focused on doing one-on-one
and then there's tribe as well but
one-on-one is the
has been your you basically take your
own
embodied experiential wisdoms that
you've taken
in and now you see that you've become
a leader figure for people in helping
them
on their journeys as well yeah i guess
so i mean
i have i have i have students and i have
teachers
you know i'm just in the middle i also
work with the savage and saint
uh consultancy i have corporate clients
so i do work as a wellness consultant
for
tech startups who want to really
optimize the well-being of their
team knowing that happy people healthy
people yes
are smart and have a lot of energy and
everybody wins
but yes most of the work is done
one-on-one
um and i work as a holistic health
practitioner so that's basically just an
umbrella term for
implementing natural means to optimize
your health vitality happiness
wellness sense of fulfillment and
the curriculum is pretty simple every
unique
body mind that comes to me has their own
you know
individual challenges and aspirations
and i don't offer a one-size-fits-all
kind of cookie-cutter approach
but i am a czech student uh paul check
is one of my mentors
and i've gone through his curriculum and
we can look at six basic pillars of
wellness
you know the more i learn about health
the more simple it all becomes
it's not necessarily easy to implement
especially in a sick society
yeah but it's very simple okay so here
are the six areas of focus
the quality of your attention the state
of your mind where does your mind go
when you're not
when you're unconscious are you
constantly generating
thoughts that are coming with afflictive
emotions
you know are you ready to
uh entertain the idea that your
mind is existing in the field of your
awareness and that you can start to
exercise some stewardship over your mind
yes okay so that's number one that's a
big one that's huge
number two is
functional breathing yes you know just
learn how to breathe watch a baby
breathe
belly cervical thoracic
whole body breathes but we go through
life and we collect
trauma and we disconnect from our body
and we disconnect from nature and we
become very shallow breathers
attached to a shallow breath is this
subtle
pervasive constant feeling of anxiety
some things are
something's wrong something's wrong some
i don't have enough
you know so just take a deep breath and
learn how to breathe properly
and you can also learn how to breathe
yourself in some pretty transcendent
states
number three sleep are you getting
enough sleep
have a look at your sleep hygiene okay
four good quality hydration
five good quality nutrition whole foods
that are not tainted with chemicals
six movement you don't have to set the
deadlift record
you can take a walk every day just move
your body in a way that feels good to
you
you check those six boxes every single
day
a lot of mental emotional spiritual
physical problems
tend to dissolve there are rules to the
game of having a flesh and bone meat
suit
and you don't have to follow them but if
you don't there's going to be problems
so here are the rules do these things
and you're going to feel better
you're going to look better you're going
to have more energy you're going to get
out of the shitty relationship you're
going to
quit the shitty job you're going to have
the courage to take the risk
have a look at your body you know it's
simple
like i said not easy but the rules are
very simple yeah
interesting so paul check has
six pillars of he's got lists he's got a
bunch of them but those are
the primary primary yeah areas of focus
with regard to one's vitality
wellness vitality and here's the
beautiful thing about him and his
curriculum
like i said i was in the gym i worked as
a fitness professional
i also had this secret life as a yogi
but when i met paul i say okay here's a
guy who's actually
he's checking both boxes he's
cultivating physical health and fitness
and well-being but it's in service of
his spiritual path
part of his spiritual path is honoring
the temple of
the organism and so i i didn't hadn't
seen that modeled before
and that's what really brought to me
together the meditation
and the fitness and the wellness is like
oh this is it
so you don't don't don't look at it as
well this is what i do for my
mental health this is what i do for my
emotional this is what i do for my
physical health
it's all connected you know it's all
spiritual
yes it's all spiritual yes yes
so for me uh staying healthy
is part of my spiritual practice yep
it's a way of saying oh thank you
creator for this
you know i didn't make this this was a
gift
i have to give it back but while i'm
here i'll take good care of it
yeah i'll explore it i'll breathe it
i'll move it
i'll let it get quiet i'll see what
secrets it has for me
all right okay
i love these pillars they're so good
simple right
they're so good and it totally makes
sense that they're simple
and then it's brought into the context
of one-on-ones
given at wherever people are tech
companies or just companies in general
and their trajectories and wanting to
augment their environments to be more
conducive to things like these pillars
of wellness
spot on spot on yeah so for me it's like
um can we review them i just i love
doing these reviews yeah yeah they're
really strong
all right cool yeah and i have a i have
my my
handy dandy you're gonna make us some
pictures my handy-dandy notebook
so number one we could say mind i love
that yeah
mind consciousness attention
and i like i like to think of these in
order of their importance
and we can think about that as okay
what you know someone said
once if you want to know what god is
think of the things you can't live
without so
these are in order consciousness is
number one if you're not conscious
you might still be alive but i don't
know are you yeah you know you're that
you're
you need you need to be conscious yeah
you need consciousness to be like so
what's number two
with regard to the survival of the
organism
you only get about three minutes without
it and then yeah you're out
so it must be pretty important and it's
worthy of exploration
20 000 of them a day and
it's one of the best ways to train the
mind
yeah and it's teaches us about the
interdependence of everything because
it's the phytoplankton the trees that
oxygenate the planet
right and it apparently
i'm still trying to figure this out but
apparently the most
dmt is produced in the body during
conscious breathing
i have a transcendent experience every
morning before i leave my house
i just breathe my way right into it as a
dmt experience
yeah you heard it here first i love it
well i studied with wim hof too and he's
yeah he'll teach you how to really trip
out on your breath
and uh yeah i've had some really uh yeah
psychedelic experiences substances too
sure
yep yeah and again that's nothing new
either yeah
don't tell them breath work forever
you know yeah but it takes a guy like
wim hall for santa's lavrov who's
charismatic and popular and gets
everyone to say oh wait a minute oh wait
yeah oh let me let me have a look at
this you know who doesn't want us to
know that
you can heal yourself with breathing
with your mind with sleeping with
nutrition hydration and movement billion
dollar companies
you know multi-billion dollar companies
and but some of them are waking up to
realize that the only way for them to
last into the next couple of decades is
for them to incorporate these
into their strategies and to also also
inclusively stakehold
all of the the employees the communities
the environment
because that's actually what's going to
gravitate more of the
gen z and generation alpha in right
would you say choose conscious breathing
no yeah well just breath just breath
yeah just so you don't have to have some
trippy transcendental breath practice
just
learn how to breathe functionally if you
ask the average person
to take a breath here's what they're
gonna do
the belly is just off the diaphragm is
just off
it's a shallow shoulder chest
constricted breath
and that comes that's stressing your
body out every time you take a breath
just open the lower abdomen in the belly
and it's just like
i'll tell my people look imagine you
wake up on vacation you're on an
island it's beautiful you got a
beautiful woman or a beautiful man next
to you what do you do you go
[Music]
yeah it just calms the system now
imagine you're having a panic attack
oh my god you're freaking out the
brother
oh my gosh so now let's take those two
extremes and inquire where
does your everyday breath when you're
not paying attention to it land on that
continuum
is it closer to the extreme panic attack
or is it closer to the
uh fully embodied relaxing breath
that's right okay so out of those 20 000
breaths per day how many of them do you
take consciously
that's another way to say sure yeah and
it's hard to dedicate
attention to even like 5 000 of them a
day
to be conscious but but to do our best
to sort of throughout the day
maybe if we can do a hundred or two
hundred or three hundred of them
take a little micro dose take three in
your hands micro dose of conscious
breathing that's the first time you've
heard of when you when you put your hand
on the doorknob before you leave your
house take a little micro dose
just take three yep and then go out into
the world
and at some point out there take another
three three just keep popping micro hits
pop
micro hits of consciousness
so next we have sleep you know we can go
longer without food and water than we
can go without sleep sleep is pretty
critical to our survival and when we
sleep
we the the body goes through physical
repairs but also mental and emotional
repairs and
sleep is regenerative in it and it's
free medicine and i work with a lot of
type a super successful dudes who think
they're doing themselves a favor by
getting up at 4 30 and going to the gym
i say you're stepping over dollars to
pick up dimes
there you go sleep for another hour and
a half you dummy yeah yeah it'd be
better for you
over dollars to pick up dimes right
that's a great way to put it
right and actually matt walker and why
we sleep uh
illustrates this point really heavily is
that you
actually can be significantly more
productive
by taking your extra hour of sleep
so that you can be at a higher state of
creativity where you don't
fall into weird strategic downfalls
during the day
right yeah yeah that's super sleep is
crucial yeah
um we got to get our eight hours and
it's best that those eight hours come
between around ten and six because we
are connected to the sun
and the rhythms of the sun so we can't
just decide that well i'm gonna get
eight hours from three a.m to 11 a.m
no no we are we've collectively evolved
to go through certain hormonal rhythms
at certain times
connect to the rhythms of the sun as the
sun goes down you start to go down as
the sun comes up you start to come up
and this is the most general
which resonates because that's most
general for the circadian rhythm of the
biological organism most generally
yet there are all of these cases like in
matt walker's why we sleep and many of
the other
scientists that have identified that
there are
these indications also in
kind of like the microbiome how it works
where some people
are cool with eating carbs some people
are cool with eating vegetables some
people
are cool with eating carnivorous diets
and so there's all these different mixes
of those and it's
somewhat similar a little bit with um
generally speaking yeah the eight hours
is an important
leg on the bar stool right for generally
speaking but then yeah there are some
people that
that uh sleep maybe three to 11
but that's again those are different
places on the on the bell curve the
general set
there's variability you just have to be
honest with yourself
there you go as does does sleeping 311
really work for me
maybe it does maybe it doesn't yeah you
got to be honest the sunlight thing is
the big thing
because if it's in the winter and it's
getting dark in the northern hemisphere
at
five o'clock p.m and you're only getting
five or six
hours of sunlight that's not as
conducive because it's really nice to
bake
out in that light for a vast majority of
people
absolutely yeah yeah so next is
hydration
good clean quality water not tap water
that's enough
of it you can go longer with without
uh food then you can go without water
so what does quality hydration look like
in terms of
um like we have
what do we have we have the mostly it's
interesting because
in san francisco when our show was there
for many years prior to this our water
comes from hetch hetchy which is
quite nice and in la
the water comes from two places the
colorado river
and then it also comes from the the
eastern side of the sierra nevadas
through the
owens valley and so it's interesting
because
it's all part of the hydrological cycle
the same water that dinosaurs drank 66
million years ago is the same water
we're drinking now
that's crazy to think about and the same
way that we're
doing what are called epps
environmentally persistent
pharmaceutical pollutants
it's what's creating the parts per
trillion of pharmaceutical
molecular structures inside of our
global hydrological cycle
and it's slowly upticking over time and
then
that's causing issues as well and so
i wonder you know what would be a
sustainable way
to make sure we're getting peak
level quality water and i would even
hypothesize
that there might even be
good ways to do longitudinal testing
because you know how people are
playing around with nootropics right now
it could be interesting to see if
there's a way to sort of do some sort of
like
you know enlightenment water right where
there is some sort of a
nootropic component to the water that
enables us to to feel greater states of
peace joy bliss that type of
of stuff so there's that well i think
that
that's already in water yeah if you get
good
clean artisanal well water or spring
water it's
it's full of minerals and those are the
north tropics that already exist
thank you mother nature that are there
to make us feel better
i tend to err on the side of nature
knows best rather than
technology to improve
water but you mentioned sustainability
and i guess there's not enough artisanal
well water for all of us to drink it
so i don't have an answer for that
question i don't know we desalinate in a
lot of places like the middle east right
now
and the more that we learn nuclear
fusion how to actually extract
more energy out than we put into fuse
atoms
then we can power desalination and many
other of our energetic
problems with burning fossil fuels and
creating
additional amounts of over 420
ppm of co2 that then acidify the oceans
that then kill the phytoplankton that
then can't oxygenate our air so it's all
interconnected like that
and so i you're i i also tend to agree
like the mycelial networks underground
that have a two-way resource exchange
with plants
that 95 percent of plants use
that that nature that knowledge
in nature that interconnected dependence
in nature
is a lot of what we talk about when we
say inclusive stakeholding protocols for
humans in our social fabrics
yeah very cool so yeah i i definitely i
definitely hear you that there's a lot
of
places like this where indigenous sort
of wisdom is definitely spot on but tech
also comes in a little bit along the way
yeah yeah so quality hydration and how
much are you drinking of water i know it
depends on each person but
well as a general rule what i'll tell my
people is take your body weight
put it in ounces cut it in half and
drink that many ounces of water per day
okay so for me i'm
around 200 pounds i'll drink 100 ounces
of water per day
yeah it's like a gallon and a half or
something so it's about a gallon
actually a gallon yeah okay
oh yeah it's about a gallon but if
here's the thing i get a nice
uh mountain spring water delivered to my
house and these big five gallon
glass drawers those big ones and it
tastes so good i drink so much water
yeah it's going to be hard to drink a
gallon of tap water a day because it
doesn't taste good
yeah but you can easily get down a
gallon of good water i mean if you're my
size
where do you get the mountain spring in
the la area uh it's mountain spring
water
it's just mountain spring water is that
the thing this is the company yeah
in the metal no they're glass they're
glass
yes and then you just give them the old
glass one they take the you take the new
one
yeah and there's also a company out of
new zealand that i got really excited
about called
zazen the zazen filter yeah so that you
can
but if you're delivered directly from it
yeah zazen's you pour
the water in and it filters yeah yeah so
that's interesting
yeah i prefer the mountain springs
bottled right there at the source and
and brought over the glass right yeah
and you just yeah so it's
sustainable in that sense interesting
okay so
that's a good one so that's four quality
hydration nutrition
nutrition now see this one's so
interesting because of the
differences in microbiomes and planetary
lineages
exactly so this is where embodiment
comes back into play
live inside your body there's people out
there that say you should eat nothing
but meat there's people out there that
say you should eat nothing but
vegetables there's people out there that
say you should uh
not eat at all watch the sun
you know and there's studies there's
studies for all of them breatharians
right so you just have to live inside
your body and start to determine
what is my body good at turning into
energy
eat more of that you know pay attention
to how your food
affects your mood if you find yourself
in a shitty mood there you go
rather than think about some childhood
trauma that's it maybe what you have for
breakfast
imagine you have a baby and the baby is
finicky
you're gonna say oh maybe something she
ate didn't agree with her maybe she
hasn't gotten enough sleep there it is
is she how does her breath look you know
but we make
our our own self-care so much more
complicated than it has to be
yeah yeah so everybody comes from
different parts of the world and our
ancestors were eating proportions of
different kind of food you know i'm
northern europe they ate a lot of meat i
eat a whole foods animal-based diet
i feel great yeah mental clarity energy
for sure you give me a bowl of rice i'm
going to enjoy it but i'm going to need
to take a nap when i'm done
yeah okay so you have to pay attention
to your body
yeah you know start to connect the dots
don't read it in a book
don't tell don't eat what someone else
told you to eat
especially what you see what happens
with people is they get trapped in an
ideology around their eating
you know like veganism for example hey
if it works for you
keep going but a lot of people there
they start to become anemic or
very frail but they told everybody that
they're vegan everybody that they know
and they told everyone that
you should be a vegan too and so now
they're ignoring their body
they're not living from the intelligence
of the body they're living from the
ideology yeah
so live inside your body your body knows
but you just have to open that line of
communication
yeah and so then finally we have
movement and like i said it doesn't have
to be
hardcore workouts it could just be
taking a walk move
in a way that feels good for you every
single day
you know take off take a hike in nature
go take your dog to the park and run
around with them
whatever you know just move we're built
to move
um the modern life is in stark contrast
to
our biology yeah and so we have to move
and when we move we feel better so you
you develop a daily
regimen around those six things yeah a
lot of problems go away now when i work
with people
they do i when i work with people who
are maybe
really out of balance with regard to
their health it's a slow process yes
i'll give you a yes to do
to a task every day and it's going to
build upon itself because what happens
is
when you start implementing these
practices you're cultivating energy
every day
yeah you're making more deposits than
you are withdrawals you have vitality so
now
so now you have the energy to make more
changes but if on day
one i say okay you're gonna meditate 25
minutes a day i need 10 minutes of
breath work
make sure you get 100 ounces of water
whole foods only and you got to work out
and
you've got to be in bed from 10 to 6.
it's overwhelming
but we can do it progressively and as
you start to make the changes you start
to feel better you start to look better
you start to
have more life force energy in your body
yes and then
you know that okay if i do this it
cultivates the life force energy if i do
this it
it's it depletes it yeah so you start to
make
wise choices because you feel the way
your lifestyle affects you yes and if
you don't feel the way your lifestyle
affects you if you live from the neck up
only
you know you you can get sick and you
can
poison yourself and people do it
unfortunately
i like this so feel the way that your
lifestyle affects you
and then hone in on enhancing vitality
i like this word vitality in in a sense
it's like
peak performance and peak performance
requires tapping in to know how
all of these things affect each
individual
uniquely and then
i love how i love how it's just funny
like
it's just funny how modernity is going
back to these
sort of like very
obvious principles very obvious super
obvious super simple
again not necessarily easy to implement
in a society that doesn't really value
these things and if you want to claim
really vibrant health and wellness for
yourself in a society where that's not
the norm
you have to be willing to do things that
most people don't do yeah
yeah and that's uh krishnamurti yeah
we're very it's no measure of well
or how to be well adjusted to assist
society
i love that guy man yeah yeah absolute
rock star yeah well
and that's why that's why it's going
back to these and for those that are
just on the audio
version one mind consciousness attention
two breath three sleep
four quality hydration five
nutrition six movement
one person that comes up for me about
movement
is ido portal i know you're gonna say
that i knew you knew that i was going to
say that too i was like this
at the men's tribe which we're going to
talk about in a moment like
this is the most simple stuff like ido
he knows what he's
he knows what he's talking about because
he literally is just biomimicking
lizards yeah you know monkeys yeah he's
bio-mimicking exactly he's biomimicking
the biology of where we come from
and so uh it's literally like doing
the like like the like the whole just
you know glide dance you know get on all
fours
definitely and yeah and just do that for
we're not again this whole thing about
incremental vitality
oh my gosh it's so simple like when
you're feeling that
that moment where it's like and it's
like i'm a stan
no stop writing that email go instead
yeah stand up
go into the sunlight go and do a little
bit of movement and stretching
and you already know this after 60
seconds you come back you feel a lot
better
right even just that one minute so it's
just that tapping in
to feel those things yeah to not
push through the yawning at 3am having
to wake up at seven it's like oh my gosh
just you know hit the hay uh you know
that's the other thing about you know
water and and
nutrition the way that makes you feel
attention that's why attention
consciousness
mind is at the top and that's why you
mentioned it at the beginning and that's
why it's so profoundly important to my
life and so many others that have went
on this path of becoming more enriched
is because the very first thing that
gives downstream to everything else
is our ability to take control of
what is this it's like
an i i i like to just make the analogy
even more uh
vicious in a sense because it really is
like
a it's like a it's like an elephant
that that drank
a bunch of cocaine water
and then and then then the you're the
little monkey that's on top of the
elephant
and the elephant is just
all day long and then the way
to the incremental change in
vitality to have the monkey slowly
take the elephant further and further
away from
using any of that cocaine water
there's a line in the way of the
bodhisattva by shanti deva
it's something like no worldly beast
however craze
could do more harm than a mind
i'm paraphrasing but until the elephant
of mind is
tethered all around by mindfulness and
then
every virtue drops into your to your
hands i love that
yeah i butchered the quote but it's
something like that but it's true it's
have a look
where does your mind go and actually
those
other five recirculate
up to the power of the mind the mind
becomes more clear
more still more concentrated more
present
there's there's an analogy that paul
told me once it was uh
you know if when you're talking about
higher states of consciousness or um
the no self experience or the non-dual
imagine a man and a wife
and a family and the man is responsible
and there's stakes in the fridge and
he's doing what he's supposed to do
and his wife feels loved and he says
babe
i'm gonna go into the woods for two days
so i need some time she's gonna say
god bless you i'll see you when you get
back okay so
that's taking care of your body so that
you can go
so consciousness can expand now imagine
that same man
he's not doing what he's supposed to do
kids are crying he
doesn't have a job the friction between
him and his wife and he says i gotta get
out of here she said what the [ __ ]
you're not going anywhere
you stay put so we're not caring for the
body
then we can't touch the the higher
states
it's it's not there's there's no
distinction
the body is the mind the mind is the
body it's the body mind you show me
where the mind stops
and the body starts come on the mind is
extrapolated all throughout the body
and beyond yeah exactly so that's it
goes back to what i said earlier
your the cultivation of your physical
health it's not about aesthetics
it's a spiritual practice and it
when that lands those you know
a lifestyle that is healthy becomes
effortless more effortless
that's it i love it it's perfect it's
perfect
so eloquent
honing in on that first principled
understanding
of i am constantly both the paradox of
being perfect as well as
constantly a work in progress of
re-baselining myself to higher states
automatically downstream creates
the proper meeting of the other five
which feedback to the first one
it's and then everything on the
self-actualization side lands as well of
your unique gifts being contributory but
you're right that um there's this very
strange
sort of economic social fabric machinery
that exists where
there's a there's a
a a mechanism of
inhibitory strides
towards that re-baselining and we have
to do our best in these next
architectures
to eradicate these inhibitory
aspects to re-baselining to those higher
states
in that machinery
let's hit
well we kind of did this but maybe
as we kind of unpack
on our way to to tribe
a difference also this is this is
important so we'll definitely have you
address this
that there's a difference
it's all one but there are these
more slightly siloed
specific sexes
of of male and female and that there's
fluidity
as well and all this type of stuff as
well but in masculinity and femininity
and balance and also at extremes and all
this type of stuff
but there's an evolutionary
rhythm that has been happening for a
long period of time that's
baked into your literal cells in your
genes
and there's just
there's a that in itself is what
people tend to call something that's
also a priori
to your existence to your awareness
and so
there's something about the evolutionary
difference between men and women
that make in many ways like men aren't
birthing children like let's just be
like right like like there's that right
there's some differences
so like what have been some of these
like clearer
evolutionary differences i mean we
talked about the
the savage one that's another pretty
clear like
evolutionary difference as well
and and also how to move to harmony
more as you've been describing what have
you seen
in that kind of like evolutionary male
archetype um do you mean to move to
harmony within oneself
yeah and also evolutionarily as as
specific
even as men in general planetarily
as we become more of enlightened
beings and match up with the divine
feminine at the same time in the
ascension i think
i think one way to really come into a
more harmonious relationship
is like you pointed out to really own
the differences
between men and women or masculine
beings and feminine beings
there's like a major movement toward
total equality
now that i think is harmful
we are balanced we're not equal not to
say that men are better than women or
women are better than men
but uh women are really naturally very
good at things that men aren't and men
are very naturally good at things that
women are yeah
and i know you had jordan peterson you
talk to him and i love what he has to
say like this idea
you know men and women have together
been struggling against nature forever
to survive
you know we're in this together yeah and
more harmonious relationships
are a byproduct of recognizing our
inherent differences
and valuing maybe for a man imagine what
it must be like to be a woman
i can remember this clear as day man i
worked as a
uh doorman and at the nightclubs for 10
years
and um wow i have some wild stories
yeah for another time around two well
fair round two
yeah no that was a very interesting line
of work yeah and it was an opportunity
to bring
martial theory into martial practice to
see what works
yeah yeah because there was always an
opportunity but anyway i can remember
this
i'm standing at the door and this woman
rolls up
and it's early in the night this was a
particularly uh
busy nightclub but there was no one
there yet it's like 9 30 or something
this woman walks up and she's by herself
and she's very she's very tiny woman
and i just check her id and um
it's her and i let her in and i watch
her go in and i'm just struck
at how small she is and i realize in
that moment for the first time ever and
i was like
27 or something i was like her life
is so much different than mine she has
to think about things that never even
occur to me
because i'm 6'3 210 pounds that's it
yeah i'm like
if someone wanted to hurt her there's
really nothing that she could do to stop
them
and it just i was like oh my god yep
and there was this like moment of
understanding and compassion and love
for her
yeah just like so i think we need to
honor our differences and and imagine
what it must be like to be each other
yep that's important yeah
exactly max stossel has a really good
bit that uh probably about a year ago
landed in my heart which was when i was
27
so super interesting that that's about
the time frame that you were saying it
max thousand has this bit where he goes
that imagine if you as a man
had like an eight or nine foot
blue giant creature that wanted
to [ __ ] you yeah yeah or you know
imagine that you're a guy and you're
just sitting in like a coffee shop and
you look up and like
four of those creatures are looking at
you like
yeah yeah yeah yeah so just just put
yourself in one another's shoes
honor the differences you know don't try
to i don't want
th this idea of a totally balanced
uh equality between the sexes that this
that dishonors are inborn gifts that's
it exactly
it feels so off to me it is off exactly
well that and that's the beauty of going
so far to that poll that we realized oh
that pulls
not not all the way to the poll come
back to the balance point
yeah because it's a quality of
opportunity in terms of enabling all of
our unique gifts to flourish with the
basic needs being met
not a quality of outcome the quality of
opportunity because people are
inherently
within our temperaments and within our
drives
we're inherently going to have different
gifts that we actualize one person's
gift of wanting to
be a good mother or father to a child is
completely different than somebody
else's gift who's
going to who's going to
architect some of those decentralized
protocols that we're talking about of
the next
generation sure that's going to yield a
different fruit
as well so we have to be yeah we
definitely have to be mindful of that
okay that's that's good i like that and
then
now let's do some of the stuff around
tribe so
we have
what appears to be
a swing into
very clear as we we've been describing
what can be called a toxic masculinity
very clear what what that is to a lot of
us
and then there's where's the like kind
of swing into the enlightened
masculinity
where's the divine masculine where's
that at where are these clubs for the
divine masculine tribe's one of them
where are the other ones
and why don't we have them what why why
don't we
make those so it's good we've identified
the dirty bath water but now we need to
take the divine masculine baby out
and propagate that throughout the world
through memes through groups
and so this is kind of you know tribe is
thousands of people from around the
world internationally
that undergo this process of what you
described with
savages and saints of developing
yeah evolving so first thing i want to
say
no disrespect yeah hit me yeah that
phrase divine masculine always just
works me a little it does okay
does it mean so many things to so many
people that it means nothing
interesting and actually interesting a
lot of the guys who really need to step
into a collective like the one i've
built
are going to hear the word divine
masculine and say nah
not for me so i just like to think of it
as practicing being a good man
good man you know just be a good man
yeah like a really solid man
cool and um we've built this community
i'm in uh with two dear friends brothers
of mine
colleagues dave burns and justin pierce
it's the three of us at the at the helm
and um it's a collective of men
dedicated to
self-mastery in their relationship with
herself
in their intimate relationships
and in their pursuit of business and
purpose you know
so my primary offering to the collective
is like what we discussed okay your
relationship with yourself
emotional healing um learning to love
the man in the mirror really that's the
healing path and when you love that man
you do no harm in the world um that you
talked about toxic masculinity that's
unexamined emotional trauma that's
leaking out on people
okay so we need to learn how to deal
with that clean up this
little corner of creation take
responsibility for your healing
yeah and then you walk you walk as
medicine
so that's my main focus you know in in
the collective
but justin he teaches spiritual intimacy
yogic sexuality tantra
um but in in a way that's not so
esoteric
and he models it because he lives it
okay he's in a beautiful relationship
for 10 years
with his business partner the mother of
his daughter and and their
they have a beautiful relationship he's
practicing what he preaches in a world
of
chronically single tantra experts okay
and dave dave's uh view of business is
like a monastery you know he approaches
his work as a vehicle for his awakening
and he's a very successful entrepreneur
and he's got some super intelligent
things to say so those are the three
pillars that we focus on
self mastery purpose and intimacy and um
you know we guys the movement is moving
and it's growing and we got guys from
all over the world
tuning in we have calls once a week and
you know another indispensable
uh resource value of tribe is
well two of them come to mind one we
discussed earlier when you create the
container
that allows for honesty and guys can be
really authentic about their what
they're struggling with
everybody collectively exhales because
you realize oh
everyone goes through this but no one
talks about it so i'm not alone here in
my suffering this is just part of being
a human being a man okay the other thing
that's
valuable in a collective is an agreement
on
critical feedback you know we will tell
you things
you will tell each other things that
everyone thinks about you but no one
says because polite society
doesn't allow for it so it's but it's
you know it's not the criticism is
offered from an open heart as a gift
yeah okay this is what you need to know
about yourself it's like oh
i never knew that i was being received
that way
yeah so it's very eye-opening and you
know everybody's different
some guys their primary focus is what
i'm offering some guys are more
interested in
what uh the intimacy some guys are more
interested in business but
just like this list that we made earlier
yeah it's the same
if you start calling a relationship with
yourself that's going to deepen your
intimacy your intimacy deepens you're
going to have more energy to go out and
succeed as you go out there and succeed
your practice of cult of cultivation of
vitality is going to become more
important because you have more to give
so it's a cycle it's a circle and they
all
are they're all influencing each other
the three pillars yeah i love it
like well as above so below like savage
and saint like
tribe i love it yeah it's it's spot on
um may we say that
within the self-mastery purpose
intimacy there is a
there's a as we we talked about this the
blooms 2
sigma is really important people that
are mentored one-on-one
perform two standard deviations above
the mean or 98
better than like the control that
wouldn't have a one-on-one
style mastery
tribe is pairing men
that have went through some of these
areas
and become more wise with men that are
entering and in need of finding men that
have went through this
sure yeah all levels come through and
there's something for everybody
sometimes
the catalyst for your growth is helping
someone else that's so spot on sometimes
you just have to show up as a basket
case and say
i'm so [ __ ] up i need help yeah but
both of those are catalysts for growth
i love that i would just say we would
want to have self-mastery then intimacy
then purpose because oh yeah
we will define self-mastery as a
one-body practice intimacy is a two-body
practice
and business as a many-bodied practice
oh that's cool so it's how are you
how are you practicing with one with
your own body
how are you connecting with another body
and how are you in the marketplace
where everyone is coming and going
exactly yeah
interesting so
for those that are listening the the
order
for for tribe is self-mastery at one
then intimacy at two because
you're doing a intimate one-on-one
relationship and like you described with
your is it justin justin yeah justin
bieber one of the co-founders justin
pearce yeah it'd be great to have
the co-founders when if they're in the
area or when they come through
i was thinking that too actually we
would love that yeah actually just a
deeper
in general collab with tribe will be an
awesome
project for us to undergo yeah yeah hell
yeah
and that with the intimacy pillar
with what you were describing with
justin and with myself as well
and with i assume many other cases with
men that this is common is that
i've had two i've had two
three year relationships
both of them have been
extremely important fundamental in my
development
and we
we need to realize that we ground
our again these self-realizations that
we have
in that intimate relationship
with someone else especially because
the way that we came into this world is
because two people
had that and then had us portaled our
consciousness into the world
and so we're gonna portal more
consciousness into the world
and so in order for that to flower and
blossom we need to
be really good at communication
really good at intimacy yeah
and so that's another reason why yeah
number two because
there's no other way for life to
continue like yeah yeah so
and then purpose makes sense on three
because that's the whole business the
many
ideas yeah yeah
it's so spot-on i love it yeah we got a
good thing going man i've been
it's been a real passion of mine to
build this along with along with my guys
and
uh i like to think we're doing good work
out in the world man we
we have a call once per week where guys
tune in from all over
all over the world and we also offer uh
usually two twice per year and in person
intensive this year being a little more
complicated we had to pivot to an online
offering uh this was just two weeks ago
actually maybe three
but it was awesome given that it was
online the depth
and the uh
the richness of the experience was
i'm just so happy to be in this work man
it makes me feel good
and as much if if
i'm giving anything to the guys who show
up that benefits them
they're showing up benefits me tenfold
yes
yeah yeah i love that so
there's a constant realization that's
been happening in my life and so many
others where it's basically this
like you described earlier with savage
and saint like you have your teachers
and then you find yourself here and then
you have your existing students and like
this is just
your students teach you through your
process of working with them
and you teach your teachers by being
their student and working with them
yeah i heard shinzen say once when the
teacher is ready the student appears
yeah yeah yeah no i think it's very
important if you're going to
uh be a teacher put your claim to be a
teacher you better be a student
too yes exactly you just have to remain
a link in the change
that's exactly you know i'm sure my
teachers i know my teachers have
teachers
i don't know maybe some of them are old
enough that most of their teachers are
dead but
yeah always remain a student i look at
my martial art teacher dana santo he's
probably 86
maybe i don't know he's in his 80s
been training for you know
seven years and he still humbles himself
and goes to someone else's class and
says oh interesting that's how you do
that oh teach me that
yeah and it's like wow that's that's
incredible
exactly you're talking about a man who's
got years in the game
you know before mixed martial arts was
even a thing he was a mixed martial
artist because he was studying all
different arts with all different
teachers but he still humbles himself
and learns
i got good role models in my life man
i'm lucky yes
staying humble even at mastery level is
beautiful
then what happens is you keep upgrading
because you
actually learn from students you learn
from other
fields of
that can augment the existing field like
there's always going to be the birth
of new edges that are pushed in
civilizations
ordering of chaos and that the birth of
the decentralization field is 12 years
old and it's
fascinating because what happens is now
everybody has
different blockchains of all different
sorts that are developing across the
planet and so
it requires somebody to realize though
that even though i'm a master
in bioengineering that
they're still unique applications and
unique ways for me to synthesize and see
what decentralization would look like in
biotech
sure stuff like that and that's when you
can really like if you're a teacher
especially
you can look at a nine-year-old we just
had a maya on the show
and the nine-year-old can literally
just ooze you wisdom and awe
but you have to have the faculties
trained to be able to
sense it and see it yeah
so tribe
is once a week yeah we have a call once
a week
what is it on a day uh it's every
thursday evening
thursday evening yeah and so zoom style
zoom yeah and um so i'll offer one i'll
host one call
and i'll teach or lecture about
something that i find inspiring that day
within the context of self-mastery but i
like to
i don't like to just sit there and talk
you know we're we're in dialogue
it's a circle yeah yeah there's there's
people who got it started but we're not
we don't we're not above anyone we're
all we're in the circle together
we talk and we share we practice that's
what sets us apart i think is that we
practice and we're endeavoring to
cultivate
daily practices that we know optimize
our
capacity as as one man
as a man who someone else is depending
on a relationship
and as a man who's wanting to succeed
with regard to his purpose
um so yeah we'll rotate i'll host a call
justin will host a call
dave will host a call and then we have
another man in a leadership position
jackson harden he'll host a call and so
there's always an opportunity just to
check in and no one ever regrets
coming to the call it's a nice little
refresh it's a nice little check-in you
feel better you have some community
and then like i said a few times a year
we get together for a residential
retreat and that's when we really dig
deep into it
yeah awesome and so is the call
you and justin and dave and jackson are
you guys doing like
modules of self mastery like what you
guys have maybe learned in the last week
that you thought were
was something exciting to share and also
you're checking in on the others in the
circle that have
goals and accountability that kind of
stuff so there's actually
one uh call per month with its specific
aim is accountability
okay so it gives everyone an opportunity
to say okay this is what i'm working on
this month and this is what i commit to
having done right next month
because you know how it is it's like one
thing to say to yourself
it's another thing to say to a group
full of guys who are gonna hold you
accountable
you know that's a beautiful gift it is a
huge gift yeah so that's that's its own
actually call once per month i love that
and then like i said my
i'll just uh i wait to see what inspires
me and i'll bring something inspiring
the call and i'll take some questions
and questions usually lead to
more discussion and but there's always
practice you know usually guided
meditation or offer some breath work or
we're talking about we're exploring a
long fast together we're going to do a
little bit
that's why you know a fungal uh protocol
to uh clean the gut so we're all in the
stuff together
you know it's it's good to challenge
yourself and when you're challenging
yourself
knowing that there's 40 other dudes in
it with you they might not be in the
same room as you
but they're in this with you then it's
that's what we say
we will go further together than we can
go alone
yeah a tribe we keep talking about how
we're returning to more ancestral
technology
what the [ __ ] is more uh primal than
tribe
that's lost today yeah we're isolated
man we're alone
we're there's more ways to connect than
ever before but we're alone
so we got to get together and that's why
we that's why we do it that's why we
circle up
and like we said like we talked about
before we got on air
it's not a boys club it's not no girls
allowed
it's we're doing this so that we can be
better men
for the women in our lives for the
children in our lives yes
and men getting together with other men
is important
yes and i'm not talking about locker
room talk or getting drunk at the
baseball game that's cool do that
but i'm talking about getting together
and being honest
yeah you know it's powerful things
happen in those circles
that change lives
love that ah what an
excellent 700th yeah yeah man that's so
good that's it seven's my lucky number
was my high school basketball number
that's awesome yeah yeah high school
basketball number lucky number seven's
one
my favorite number i love it
boom wow
all right
let's see
man we've hit so many good things i'm so
damn happy
i'm so damn proud of us
we cruised through this so beautifully
i'm really glad to be connected with you
thank you for this invitation likewise
michael yeah and shaker pie
again pointed me in the direction of
reaching out good luck shaker i hope i
can meet you one day hell yeah yeah we
showed we showed up um we showed michael
a picture of us together shaker and yeah
and
and uh we will we'll definitely bring
the boys
the men together i'm really glad that
what's
cooking is exactly what is needed right
now you're facilitating
just a quick thought about it is um
are there different like tiers of
involvement in terms of
is there free and paid and well there's
a free
facebook group if you're on facebook um
you know it's facebook but it's a good
way to connect and
get on the uh bulletin board and see
what's coming
there's one level of engagement and it's
simply ten dollars per month and that
gives you access to four calls per month
ten
ten ten dollars a month yeah i mean
really i mean that's ridiculous that's
yeah that's that's it's a no-brainer
it's a no-brainer good
you know i guess i'm biased but i love
it it's quality
how many boys come into the how many men
come into each one of the weekly
um i guess we've had as many as 50
yeah and but the ranks are building
yeah exactly the ranks are building yeah
so um
and yeah like i said we have our
in-person intensives hopefully
next year or something we can get those
back online but
the movement is moving and if you're a
man listening to this
and you want to join a community of men
that are dedicated to
purpose freedom and love
um that are dedicated to becoming the
best versions of themselves
and are willing to hold you accountable
to do it
then spend ten dollars a month man and
join us on the calls because you're
invited
you know all men are welcome all men are
welcome we are unified
only by our allegiance to personal
growth through practice
come get down ah i love it i love it
that link is in the bio below again
everyone
let's uh let's unpack uh one last thing
which is i wonder what you think the
nature
of reality is in general why do these
realities
exist man you just save the light
question for the end
easiest question at the end that's right
i don't even know where to begin with
that
why does reality exist yeah
it's an opportunity maybe for god
to know god
maybe complete unity
with no duality for eternity upon
eternity upon eternity
gets kind of boring so god splendored
god's self off into you and me
and trees and birds and everything so
that god
can see god and maybe this reality
exists for
us to realize that we are
it yeah and we came here to taste all
the flavors the good the bad and the
ugly
and all of it is offered to nudge us
awake
beautiful eternally tasting flavors
yeah this whole idea of like
if we use our imagination we just go
beyond
the four limb two-eyed
carbon-based dna encoded creature that's
in this specific style of soul vehicle
we
just use our imagination there's so many
other styles of soul vehicles that will
have so many other styles of
tasting of phenomenology that exists
so all these different qualius it's hard
for people to imagine
even a color outside the color wheel
and so then like now you start like okay
well if i try to do that one well
what about you know what are other
states of
qualia experience that exist so
eternally exploring that cyclically
all the different ones seems to be
a
theme that even cutting edge science is
now starting to validate even sir roger
penrose who won
the nobel prize in physics in 2020
believes in cyclic
cosmology i love this
i love this quote this quotes
it's so good he says
this is in this is in chapter
10 of high-level perception infinity
there was something before the big bang
and that something is what we will have
in our future
sir roger pedros that's like a go on
i like it yeah yeah so
uh oh yeah and last silly playful
question
what's your favorite food
it's hard to pick just one although
lately it's been hard for me to beat a
nice
pastured grass fed
medium rare salted
buttered rib eye steak
yup yup i'm getting a little hungry just
thinking thinking about it yeah
we've had that answer before you went
into the most detail
on the rib eye i like that do you do
sides
sure what do you do for sides um
mostly above ground vegetables
and uh kimchi avocado things like that
if i'm feeling like relaxing the regimen
then a good the best side for actually
there's three best sides for room you
said
you said you're i part irish yeah so you
already know one of them
mashed potatoes i like a baked potato
baked potato okay
number two portobello mushroom oh number
three
fried onions oh my gosh those are all so
good
yeah and what do you go for above ground
like asparagus or what are you talking
about yeah well i just it's like
like i said um i prefer foods with a
lower glycemic index oh sure because uh
my body just is much better at being me
when there's a lot of fat and not a lot
of carbohydrate yeah yeah so yeah above
ground vegetables you like asparagus
spinach
you know okay things like that leafy
greens yeah but then when you go below
the ground the potatoes the sweet
potatoes stuff like that that's when
your boy starts getting sleepy sleepy
yeah yeah oh my gosh sounds so good
i know that's a good choice yeah
and you're you said medium rare was your
yeah was your
uh amount of cookedness preparedness
interesting
grass-fed though some butter some salt
mm-hmm yeah lots of butter lots of lots
of butter lots of salt yeah yeah
interesting yeah you you and you like
the fattier
because of the ribeye you get a little
more fat some marble yeah
have you had a weigh you yeah
yeah you have yeah that's i
for my first time i had that when i was
kind of finishing up
high level perception and
it was really good yeah someone told me
that
it's like uh
like drinking steak
yeah i was like that's that's kind of
what it's like
that's kind of it's like so yeah
yeah there's a is something really
special about um
in a very sustainable way and
have you heard of growing meat in
bioreactors
and yeah you're yeah it's not natural
for yeah exactly it's interesting i
don't know yet we we have to do
longitudinal tests because there's a lot
of people
in silicon valley doing the whole
biotech thing and it's exciting because
i got you know into it as well and then
one of the things is that i just wonder
like if you do grow
and do things like try and proliferate
stem cells on these
collagen scaffoldings inside of massive
bioreactors
you know you just wonder if that me
eating
a rib eye or with you of that
growth is going to longitudinally give
me
similar better or worse life effects
one of my friends uh tristan he says
that
benefit of doing the grass-fed meat is
that the animal
acts as a juicer right yeah yeah
a lot of environmental problems can be
solved if we return the ruminants to the
soil
and yeah that's and that's the cycle
that's been existing so it's it's a
very very interesting sort of what we're
going to figure out in the next couple
of decades
around that so i guess we'll see how
that that space
evolves but eat what feels yeah right
but we also have to be careful
sorry just slight thing also is that we
have to be careful inside of all those
packages
of the alternative based foods
uh alternative meats and alternative all
this different type of stuff cheeses and
all these things like be really careful
like what is on the back of the you know
what's on the ingredient list yeah yeah
so just be careful that's it
michael holt thanks so much for coming
on the show bro appreciate you man
what a dope show what a good one
thank you namaste out of the divine in
you my man likewise
love it what an incredible journey what
an incredible 700th show
i love it all things masculinity
spirituality well-being i love the
breakdowns
super super rich breakdowns
again because we love to do brief
reviews
one mind consciousness attention
and that goes to breath sleep
quality hydration nutrition movement and
those have a feedback loop to the first
and then self mastery intimacy
purpose
yes anyone wants to connect um my
website savagensaint.com
and links in the bio yeah link in bio
tribe men's biotribemenscommunity.com
i'm on instagram savage insane so all
those links in the bio below
go follow michael go and sign up for
tribe
please please check it out check out
savage and saint as well
michael's website check that out
send the link to people that especially
men
that need to learn about what
the good men community is like
send the link around like the video
subscribe
comment below with your thoughts on the
video
continue supporting the artists the
entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders the
scientists
engineers that you believe in your
communities and around the world you can
support simulation our links are below
to our show
700 of these in a route
to a really powerful 2021
got a lot of epicness coming i know you
do
look at these flowers these flowers of
all the guests that we have on the show
all the different content that they're
sharing with you
all different opportunities that they're
sharing with you so jump on
that's all folks all right thanks for
checking us out
thank you thank you build the future
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in
we will see you soon
peace